foreign
thank you
um
you
next
here
oh
guys
oh
oh
hello
so
so
oh
so
okay
so
so
foreign
so
now
now
so
morning
so
oh
oh
all right
so
okay
so
okay
this
you
um
you
um
church
you
you
so
thank you
so
uh
uh
so
okay
um
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
thank you very much thank you
great honor to be with you today and
being here
is a real uh really important moment as
far as i'm concerned
my first duty as president is to protect
the american people
and today i'm taking action to fulfill
that sacred obligation
in recent weeks there's been a radical
movement to defund dismantle and
dissolve our
police departments extreme politicians
have joined this
anti-police crusade and relentlessly
vilified our law enforcement heroes
to look at it from any standpoint the
effort to shut down
policing in their own communities has
led to a shocking
explosion of shootings killings murders
and heinous crimes of violence
this bloodshed must end this bloodshed
will end
today i'm announcing a surge of federal
law enforcement into american
communities plagued by violent crime
will work
every single day to restore public
safety
protect our nation's children and bring
violent
perpetrators to justice we've been doing
it and you've been seeing what's
happening
all around the country we've just
started this process
and frankly we have no choice but to get
involved
with us today is attorney general bill
barr
thank you bill very much acting dhs
secretary chad wolfe chad thank you
and fbi director christopher ray thank
you chris very much
we're also pleased to be joined by
americans who have tragically lost their
loved ones
to recent violence to each of you please
know that america grieves with you
that we pledge to honor the memory of
your cherished
loved ones by fighting to bring safety
in
every single community we will bring
that safety
you will see for decades politicians
running many of our nation's major
cities have put
the interests of criminals above the
rights of law
abiding citizens these same
politicians have now embraced the far
left movement to break up
our police departments causing violent
crime in their cities to spiral
and i mean spiral seriously out of
control
in new york city over 300 people were
shot
in the last month alone a 277
at least percent increase over the same
period
of a year ago murders this year have
spiked 27
in philadelphia 94 in minneapolis
compared to the same period in 2019
perhaps no citizens have suffered more
from the
menace of violent crime than the
wonderful people of chicago a city i
know very well
at least 414 people have been murdered
in the city this year a roughly 50
increase over last year more than 1
900 people have been shot these are
numbers that aren't
even to be believed yesterday alone
23 people were shot in chicago including
at least 15 who were shot
in a merciless onslaught of gunfire
outside of a funeral home
63 people were shot in the city this
past weekend and at least 12
people were killed over the 4th of july
weekend
nearly 80 people were shot and 17
were killed over father's day weekend
104 people were shot and 15 were killed
including five
young children and the last weekend in
may saw the city's deadliest day on
record
18 murders in 24 hours
behind each of these horrifying
statistics is a victim a family a loved
one
and a life of cruelly shattered and
it's just so sad to see and so sad to
look
and so sad to see how these lives have
been just torn apart
an african-american father of three was
killed while walking into a store to pay
his cell phone bill a 13 year old girl
was killed when a stray bullet came
through the window of her home
and hit her in the neck in the presence
of her family
on independence day 14 year old renato
jones jr was playing basketball with
friends in a chicago park
when he was senselessly killed in a
massacre that left eight people dead or
wounded
bernardo's mother cheryl is here with us
today
and cheryl please know that all
americans mourn
by your side we will carry your son's
memory
he will not be forgotten cheryl
cheryl thank you very much thank you for
being here cheryl
thank you very much it's a great honor
to meet you before thank you
this rampage of violence shocks the
conscience of our nation
and we will not stand by and watch it
happen
can't do that the citizens of chicago
are citizens of america
and they have the same right as every
other american to live in safety dignity
and peace
no mother should ever have to cradle her
dead child in her arms simply because
politicians refused to do what is
necessary
to secure their neighborhood and to
secure their city
every american no matter their income
their race or their zip code should be
able to walk their city streets
free from violence and free from fear
for this reason today i am announcing
that the department of justice will
immediately surge
federal law enforcement to the city of
chicago
the fbi atf dea
u.s marshals service and homeland
security will together be sending
hundreds of skilled law enforcement
officers to chicago
to help drive down violent crime
and murderers and violent criminals are
breaking a wide range of federal laws
we have that it's as wide as it can be
we will find them arrest them and
prosecute them
they will be in jail for many years to
come and we will work with local police
to identify
violations of state and local laws to
help ensure
that offenders are caught and jailed for
their crimes
but we must remember that the job of
policing a neighborhood falls on the
shoulders of local
elected leadership never forget that
when they abdicate their duty the
results are catastrophic
americans must hold their city leaders
accountable
they must insist that community
officials fully support
fully back and fully fund their local
police departments
there is simply no substitute for a
police department that has the strong
backing of city leaders
in the meantime we will use federal law
enforcement to vigorously charge federal
crimes and support these besieged
communities
to the greatest extent possible this
will be hard
painstaking work it will take time
the tide will not recede overnight but
we will marshal
all of the strength and focus and
determination
that we can possibly do this is a
critical effort
we will continue to call on state and
local leaders to do their job
and protect their citizens the operation
in chicago will be done
as part of operation legend which was
recently launched in kansas
city missouri and very successfully i
might add
it is named after legend talifaro a
four-year-old boy who's
shot think of this he was shot and
killed last month
while he lay asleep in his home legends
mother grieves
our hearts and pains and souls and we
thank you very much for being here
thank you very much thank you very much
appreciate it
we are profoundly grateful to be joined
by
sharon would you please stand sharon
sharon please
uh and also legends father rafael and
his grandparents
alfred and pauline yes
he looks so great so great thank you
very much i appreciate your nice
statements before too
thank you very much thank you
legend is looking down he's very proud
of you right now
tell you thank you very much to legends
family we cannot even begin to imagine
your anguish and your sorrow but we
solemnly promise
to honor legend and we will be fighting
every day to save the lives of
america's children under operation
legend we will
also soon send federal law enforcement
to other cities
that need help other cities need help
they need it badly they should call they
should want it
they're too proud or they're too
political to do that
one of them is albuquerque new mexico
where last fall 55 year old jackie v
hill was murdered as she was getting
into her car
to go to the gym we're joined today by
her husband sam and her
sons raul and kevin
both new mexico state police officers
would you please stand
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much i appreciate it thank you
great looking family thank you very much
to sam
raoul and kevin we'll move beyond words
by your presence here today we thank you
very much for being here it's a great
honor to meet you
this afternoon i'm also announcing that
the department of justice will provide
more than
61 million dollars in grants to hire
hundreds of new police officers and
cities that are
the focus of operation legend
we will never defund the police we will
hire
more great police we want to
make law enforcement stronger not weaker
what cities are doing is absolute
insanity
may have the same politicians who want
to slash resources for
law enforcement have also declared that
their cities are sanctuaries full
criminal illegal aliens
in other words after arresting illegal
aliens for crimes the police are ordered
to release those
criminals back onto the streets to
continue
their crime last year chicago
politicians forced the release of
illegal aliens charged with crimes
such as assault armed robbery
strangulation and
attempted murder my administration will
be working to remove dangerous offenders
sprung loose by these deadly policies
and frankly
by these deadly politicians america must
be a sanctuary for law-abiding citizens
not criminal aliens
my vision for america's cities
could not be more different from the
lawlessness being pushed
by the extreme radical left while
others want to defund defame
and abolish the police i want to support
and honor
our great police while the radicals want
to abolish
charter schools and eliminate school
choice i want to expand school
choice and every family in america
should have that option
while others want to destroy opportunity
shut down businesses and send our jobs
overseas
we are hiring americans and we are
buying
american product we want to build
factories in baltimore not
beijing we want to make our products in
chicago not shanghai
we want the american dream for american
children and i will
fight to deliver that dream every ounce
every single ounce of my strength i will
be fighting
but opportunity cannot thrive where
there is violence
prosperity cannot flourish where there
is bloodshed
and security cannot exist where there
are violent criminals
who are able to maim and murder with
impunity
that is what operation legend is all
about
that is why we are here today to answer
the pleas of those crying for justice
and crying for help for those people in
chicago and other cities where we'll be
help is on its way i'd now like to ask
attorney general
william barr is doing a fantastic job to
explain
operation legend in greater detail
followed by acting secretary wolf
and then we'll hear from loved ones of
fallen americans i'll ask
sam v hill and sharon powell
to the podium and we'd love to hear them
say a few words in honor of their loved
one thank you very much
please bill
thank you mr president and i'd like to
thank especially uh
the families of the victims who have
come here today
and have allowed us to inaugurate this
effort
in the name of their loved ones
and i'd like to thank all our law
enforcement colleagues
from around the country state local and
federal
as president said the first duty of
government
is to protect the safety of our citizens
and we're here to explain
the initiative to combat rising violent
crime
in a number of our cities our goal is to
help save lives
the principal danger to the lives of our
inner city
communities is violent crime
the leading cause of death for young
black males
is homicide each year approximately 7
500
black americans are the victims of
homicide
every one of those lives matter
in 1992 violent crime was
nationwide was double
what it is today and it was at that time
that federal law enforcement first
turned its attention to this kind of
violent crime before that the federal
government really didn't play that much
of a role in it
but we started to attack violent crime
in conjunction with state and local
government
it was at that time for example that the
fbi set up
its ganked anti-gang task forces
throughout the united states
and we started using our strong federal
laws
that permit us to target those who use
guns
to kill others and those that are
involved in gang activity
our approach was to set up anti-violent
crime task forces in the cities to
enforce
federal law and take the shooters
and the chronic violent criminals off
the streets
we helped pay for state and local
officers to
join these task forces so we could
leverage our strength
and this approach was extremely
successful
in the intervening decades in driving
crime down
now at the end of the obama
administration crime started going back
up again
and for the first two two and a half
years of this administration we were
succeeding and pushing it down
but less than a year ago mr president
you'll recall that as we saw
crime starting to go up in a few cities
you asked me to initiate a surge in
those cities to help our state local
partners deal with it
and so we did start this program which
we called relentless pursuit
unfortunately covet intervened and we
had to abort that
that effort and since then we had that
terrible
event in minneapolis but then we had
this
extreme reaction that has demonized
police
and called for the defunding of police
departments
and what we have seen then is a
significant increase in violent crime in
many in
cities and this this rise is a direct
result
of the attack on the police forces
and the weakening of police forces and
the president's gone through
the terrible statistics
so in response to that
uh we have initiated this program
operation legend to step up the activity
of our task forces
our anti-crime task forces in the
hard-hit
cities by committing more federal agents
and supporting more state and local task
force officers
it's important to stress that the
operations we're talking about are the
standard
anti-crime fighting activities we have
been carrying out around the country
for decades we will be adding federal
agents to the task forces
these are street agents they're
investigators who will be working
to solve murders and to take down the
violent
gangs and they'll be working shoulder to
shoulder with our state and local
colleagues
this is a different kind of operation
obviously
than the tactical teams we use to defend
against riots and mob
violence and we're going to continue to
confront
mob violence but the operations we're
discussing today
are very different they are classic
crime fighting
we've named the operation as we've said
operation legend
and we started rolling it out a couple
of weeks ago in kansas city
and just to give you an idea of what's
possible the fbi
went in very strong into kansas city and
within two weeks
we've had 200 arrests
we will be adding cities in the weeks to
head
and for now we're including beyond
kansas city as the president said
chicago and albuquerque
the fbi is today announcing rewards for
information related to the killing of
legend
jackie and vernada
we are seeking justice for those victims
today and operation legend
aims to immediately help our police
agencies and our local leadership to
prevent additional victims
the fbi has established a hotline for
the public to report
information they may have that may help
in solving
these murders the hotline number is
1-800
call fbi to carry out
operation legend federal law enforcement
agencies will be committing additional
resources to these cities including
fbi agents dea
etf us marshals and the department of
homeland security
hsi teams
today we have sent over 200 federal
agents to kansas city
we are directing a comparable
number of agents to augment chicago's
existing task forces
and we are providing an additional 35
agents
to albuquerque the united states
attorneys for chicago albuquerque and
kansas city are here today
these u.s attorneys and the chief
federal law enforcement officials in
each of these cities
are ultimately responsible for
coordinating the federal effort
and ensuring prosecutions from these in
this this initiative
are effective linked to this increase in
federal law enforcement agents
we are also providing additional
financial assistance
to the state and local enforcement
agencies to permit them to provide
more cops more members of our task force
as i said federal agents work hand in
glove with state and local enforcement
law enforcement every day
we supplement and provide support to
local law enforcement but violent crime
is ultimately
a problem that will be solved by state
and local leadership in these cities as
the president said
our announcement today is a
demonstration of our commitment
to the men and women who serve as police
officers
in chicago albuquerque and kansas city
your efforts to protect these
communities
are not forgotten so too this
announcement and operation
legend as a whole is also a commitment
to the families of legend
tal pharaoh jackie verhill
and vernado james that those names will
not be forgotten
we will not rest until justice is
delivered
for your loved ones thank you well mr
president thank you
for the invitation to be here today it's
always an honor to discuss
the actions to protect and defend the
peace and liberty we value in this
country
attorney general barr partnership our
departments have in executing a shared
mission of protecting the homeland and
bringing justice to those who threaten
it remains as strong as ever so thank
you for your partnership
as the nation's largest law enforcement
agency the department of homeland
security stands ready
and able to commit our highly skilled
highly trained homeland security
investigative special agents to help
restore
law and order in the wake of 9 11 dhs
was founded
so that the federal government could
better partner directly with state
and local law enforcement as dhs
supports this critical effort led by the
department of justice
homeland security investigative agents
will leverage their networks their
assets
and their expertise to energize criminal
investigations
homeland security investigation's
mission is to investigate some of the
most violent criminals
specifically those involving
transnational gangs and narcotics
trafficking
let me just take a quick moment to
clearly make a distinction as the
attorney general did
about what is occurring in portland
versus the important action that we're
announcing here today
in portland we see almost two months of
coordinated violent
attacks by anarchists against a federal
courthouse and federal law enforcement
officials
sworn to protect it in chicago we see an
unprecedented rise in crime
against fellow citizens the dhs mission
in portland is to protect federal
property and our law enforcement
officers
in chicago the mission is to protect the
public from violent crime on the streets
leaders of these great cities should not
stand behind the status quo
they should stand with america they
should condemn these violent attacks
and they should work with this
administration and this president to
bring about law and order
i know everyone standing here today
every homeland security investigations
agent assigned to operation legend
and every reasonable american agrees
with the basic premise
that every four-year-old should be safe
at night to sleep in their bed the
department grieves
with all the families experiencing
excruciating and heart-wrenching stories
of loss
we as a department stand resolute
committed to working together across the
federal government
with our state and local law enforcement
partners to keep that promise
so again thank you mr president
department is grateful for your
continued support
of our law enforcement officers as we
continue to ensure the safety and
security of all americans
thank you chris you want to say a few
words please you're going to be a big
part of it
come on go ahead please
the real measure of success of
initiatives like operational
legend is the ability of communities to
feel
safe it's not about the number of
arrests it's about the ability of
kids to be able to play outside of their
homes
about families to be able to to walk to
and from work
and that's what this operation is
designed to do
and it's going to be a significant surge
of federal resources to partner with our
great state and local law enforcement
partners
to achieve safety and the confidence
that the american people need to have
that they can live safe in their
community so thank you mr president
please please sir
i would start up by thanking you for
you know i never imagined that i would
be in the same room with the most
powerful person on earth
and thank you mr president uh thank you
mr bart
i i would like to just very briefly uh
make a few comments about my wife the
way she was
jackie was the type of person that
loved to go to the gym that was one of
her big things
she also liked to send out
prayers on a daily basis to people she
would pick
verses from the bible uh prayers that
she came across
with and she would either email those
prayers or tweet them to some of the
some of her friends there in albuquerque
that all ended on
november 19th um you know as i mentioned
before
she was one of those people that had to
go to the gym otherwise she wouldn't
make it through the day we usually get
up around 4 30
before 45 uh she got up
i got up i went downstairs i got my
cup of coffee uh she came down and she
says well
you know i'll see you in about an hour
that's about how long she would spend
the
the gym um i heard the garage door open
uh and then all of a sudden almost
immediately after that i heard
the uh the horn on the car
so i went out there and i uh i thought
maybe
you know maybe she forgot her gym card
or something and wants me to go out
there and take it back to her
uh when i opened the door hi the garage
door was open
there was a vehicle behind hers blocking
her
um and i still didn't snap i thought
well maybe
the guy that delivers the paper usually
around that time of day or
you know was the one in the back of her
car
then i noticed that that that wasn't so
she gave somebody a shot and killed her
there
i saw a person walk over on the driver
i mean on the passenger passenger side
of the the vehicle that was behind her
and get on and take off like crazy
to this day i can't forget that you know
every every time i go to bed every time
i go out into the
driveway that that memory comes back and
it hunts me
and and jackie my wife did not deserve
to be killed that way
nobody does you know of course
albuquerque as
you probably all know those of you in
law enforcement has a reputation for
being one of the
violent most violent cities in in the
country actually you know we've ranked
up there in
first place second place and
uh that doesn't seem to be going away
you know it's been
eight months since my wife died and
there's been no arrests at all nobody
has been arrested for the crime
there are other victims in albuquerque
that are in the same boat that the
journal reported back of a couple of
months ago that the
solve sub the rate of solving
homicides in albuquerque was less than
50 percent
you know and that in itself tells you a
big story as to where we're at how we
we need desperately some help to to get
after
the crime rates that we have going on
there and
i am i really appreciate the effort
that you all are putting into this and i
welcome that and if there's anything
that i can do please let me know
thank you both so much thank you very
much simon we're going to be giving a
special effort to that when we
go and we have some very talented people
going in we're going to give give a very
special effort
to jackie okay thank you very much
sharon please thank you
thank you i appreciate the efforts
um good afternoon i am sharon powell
i am legends holopherol's mother i want
to thank god for giving me the strength
to withstand today
operational legend is not to harass it's
not to harm
or to hurt it is to help investigate
unsolved murders
in which one of those happens to be our
innocent four-year-old son
this operation is personal to us we want
justice for our son
and others we have to take a stand in
our communities
and speak up to help this operation be
successful
my one and only child who fought through
open heart surgery
at four months is gone due to senseless
gun violence
children are supposed to be our future
and our four-year-old son didn't make it
to kindergarten
i stand here today as a mother fighting
against violence for my son legentale
pharaoh
my family and i support operation legend
and we strongly want
our community and everyone else behind
us thank you so much you guys i
appreciate all the efforts um
one thing about legend he was
he was exciting he loved basketball
um he was a ball of joy and
i want his legacy to live on and i want
us to continue to fight against violence
and also get justice
for my son and others so with this
operation
i want it to be successful so if every
community can
reach out to that high line if you know
any information about any murder
that would be great and also to keep
karen on this legacy
um thank you once again i appreciate
everything thank you
thank you very much and legend and
jackie are looking down right now at you
and
very proud very proud thank you both
thank you families for being here thank
you
so to every family i'm very proud to
stand with you in this struggle i'm
proud to stand with the heroes of law
enforcement they are true heroes thank
you all for being here we appreciate it
very much great great people and i'm
proud to fight by your side to deliver a
better future for the citizens of every
race color religion in crete
as soon as the cities and states call to
ask for help
on a very large basis we will be there
with full force and we will stop this
horrible situation very quickly but in
the meantime we're doing something
that's going to have
an impact and mr attorney general thank
you very much
chad thank you very much do a good job i
have no doubt you will thank you
thank you very much thank you see you
later thank you
hmm
you